Patrick thanks so much for joining us
congrats the newest Detroit Redwing
Henrik lunis has the first question here
ker uh obviously a lot of speculation
where you were going to end up can you
take us through your thought process of
making this
decision yeah I think uh probably about
two or three weeks ago we started uh
interviewing with teams that uh were
either interested or I was interested
and uh kind of went from there um uh so
you know it was uh it was a tough
decision for sure um especially you know
through the whole process it was felt
like a long time you know it's been
about almost 6 months since the surgery
so you never really know when where
you're going to play next and uh um you
know I think my my heart was in Detroit
you know I would I would think about a a
place and uh be all about that place for
a day and then you know my heart and my
mind would U for for some reason always
come back to Detroit so it seemed like
the uh the right fit for me and I was uh
you know obviously happy they were
interested as well caner congratulations
it's Ace uh how much of the impact did
Stevie Ean have in your decision to sign
for the Detroit Red
Wings yeah it was big I mean it was uh
you know I came away very impressed uh
talking to him and uh and the head coach
Derek band here uh with our meeting and
um you know there's just a certain
presence about him obviously when you
talk to him and he seems very dialed in
I think uh they definitely wanted to go
through the process the right the right
way too and just you know making sure
they were happy with where I was at
physically and uh happy with um you know
everything that went on with the surgery
and and all that so um it was nice to
kind of clear all the physicals
yesterday and get done with all that and
um I think everyone was pleased and uh
go from here Patrick you said that you
were thinking about different teams but
every time your heart kept coming back
to Detroit when you kept going back to
mowtown and see in that City how often
were you seeing Alex to Brink it and
thinking about the things you guys did
together in Chicago yeah I mean that's
that's a huge reason there's no doubt
about it had a lot of success with him
in uh in Chicago playing there the last
couple years we were there and um he's a
great kid he's a fun kid to be around I
think we were uh we were very close on
the ice obviously but even even off the
ice as well he became one of my one of
my better friends so enjoy being around
him every day just his competitiveness
the way he loves the game he loves
hockey his uh his passion for the game
and um I think one of the things I
really respected about him was just um
you know the fact that he wasn't he
wasn't afraid to tell me what to do on
the ice or or give it back to me if we
were you know getting a little bit
heated on the bench or something like
that so a lot of respect for him and it
was uh it was a big reason Showtime Biz
here uh first off I think I speak for
all hockey fans well we're pumped to see
you back uh one of the best American
born players ever if not the best
American Born player I have a two-part
question how grew scholing was the
surgery and process of all of it as far
as Rehabilitation and is there anything
about your stride or anything that
you've had to change after getting this
resurfacing
surgery yeah so I mean I tried to work
hard at the rehab obviously and um put a
lot of time and effort into it um you
know the thing about it was like two or
three days after the surgery I wasn't
feeling the pain that I was feeling the
last couple of years so it was almost
refreshing right away obviously a big
surgery and uh um you know when you're
here four to 6 months or it was probably
always like six six or seven months to
be honest with you um you know it's
going to be a long time but put in the
time and effort and um you know feel a
lot better as far as the stride change
um no I don't think so I mean if if
anything I'm able to uh put a lot more
weight onto the right side now which I
wasn't able to do the last couple
Seasons so I feel like my my lateral
movement and my agility is a lot better
than it was and even just my stride in
general doesn't feel like I'm kind of
flaring out my hip or anything I can I
can fully extend so feels good on a lot
of fronts just um you know it will be uh
it'll be nice to get back in game action
here and uh and get going and um start
playing hockey again I got one more
followup I don't want to get Detroit
fans too excited but how confident are
you you can get back to the Patrick
kaning we've seen come playoff time the
one doing the pumper nickel and the
heartbreaker to that
level yeah very confident very confident
um you know I know for a fact I'm going
to be better than I was was last year
and even the year before I mean put up
decent numbers but it was uh I I
couldn't really I couldn't really move
laterally side to side a lot of a lot of
my plays were just kind of uh Peg Leg
planted so it was uh um it was a good
decision I'm happy with it all and um
very confident about getting back to a
to a high level of
play